Perfect queen-of-everything,
Beyoncé, was finally proven
mortal this past weekend,
when her earring ripped out
during a performance,
causing her to emit
what appears to be human blood.
Uh, she's fine, I think?
She's used to it.
Beyoncé blood is what
the Illuminati use to begin
their Christmas parties.
-(laughter)
-So she'll be fine.
(applause and cheering)
She'll be fine.
And she finished the concert
like a pro,
but some of the more fervent
members of the Bae Hive
are showing their solidarity
by making themselves bleed...
-(Hardwick laughs) -Oh, no!
-(laughter and groaning)
What is our culture?
...with the hashtag
#CutForBeyonce.
-Oh, God! -Uh...
-(groaning)
This is ridiculous,
especially considering
not a single person showed
their solidarity last year
with the hashtag
#WhipYourDickOutForLennyKravitz.
-Nobody.
-(laughter)
-(cheers and applause)
-There he is. -Ah.
CONOVER:
He has known
-struggle, too, you know.
-Yeah.
♪ It wants to get away.
(laughter)
Comedians...
It looks like it hurt real bad.
HARDWICK:
It... (laughs)
Comedians... what are people
doing in solidarity
with other musicians?
-Jonah.
-Um...
in solidarity,
fans of Sublime are sucking.
-HARDWICK: Aw, Jesus Christ.
-(laughter)
You know, they had
some good songs, Jonah.
-No, they didn't.
-All right, points.
(laughter)
(Hardwick laughing)
-Adam. -In solidarity
with Keith Richards,
fans are hiding heroin
in their walkers.